citizens of the reject Nation Greg is being
solo today because I asked around to everyone
who comes on this channel and my biggest fears
have been confirmed I am the only one who
has not seen the much beloved Christopher
Nolan classic Memento I started at insomnia
all the way to Oppenheimer have not seen this
one though it's been one of those movies that
I've just been wanting to watch on my own
time I have no idea how well this video will
do but I figured if I was planning already
watching it just to play some ketchup might
as well point the camera at me while I'm experiencing
this film and then ruin the experience for
all of you with that in mind a few things
I want to mention first off this reaction
upcoming is going to be edited by the team
over at prepper and I'm not going to have
any time to review their edit so if it's crap
blame them and if it's great in your need
of an editor I highly recommend them they're
generally pretty freaking awesome people secondly
please go ahead leave a like that'd be extremely
appreciated if you can go ahead and do that
and as always full-length Reaction watch along
where you sync up with your own copy of memento
available for our super sexy rejects those
are our patrons and thank you again to all
you citizens who have converted yourselves
to super sexy citizens over there we have
ourselves uh many things that we cover exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch alongs
included well with the limited amount I know
which is I believe this movie's told backwards
obviously Guy Pierce is in it and it's a Noir
film those are my facts everything else it's
gonna be a big process of discovery let's
get into it
[Music]
Polaroid of a crime scene
Ah that's clever I just picked up on it
[Music]
I was late to pick it up on that
strange it actually goes backwards the whole
time
come on oh damn you're in some hotel room
you just wake up and you're in in a motel
room there's the key you've been there for
a week three months cool this guy he's here
all right Lenny it's a Leonard like I told
you before yeah I must have forgot I love
Joe pantaliana so he killed him my car this
is your car oh you're in a playful mood it's
not good for you to make fun of someone's
handicap interesting all right well if you
win them how did the window get to be that
way so where to Sherlock I got a lead on the
place that's just this building why do you
want to go there I don't remember [Laughter]
it kind of feels like a Michael Mann movie
looks like somebody's home uh that thing's
been here for years we're talking about these
tracks for only a few days old
take a look inside so as long as the time
span of his ability to remember stuff Teddy
don't believe his lies he is the one kill
him I finally found him find anything I kind
of like his detached Noir performance
yeah cool you freak beg my wife's forgiveness
before I blow your brains out wife's forgiveness
you don't know who you are I'm Leonard Shelby
I'm from
Sam come you want to know any oh that's a
good mystery let's go down you were made together
you'll know who you really are no
tisk Sammy Jank has had the same problem but
he he really had no system you really do need
a system if if you're gonna make it work like
it's like the early stages of his career development
of an obsessed pedantic intelligent white
man and a loner too
all right okay so this is the scene before
the okay yeah I hope this does not hurt my
head I'm not sure I think I may have asked
you to hold my calls you don't know it's my
memory Amnesia no no no I know who I am I
know all about myself I just since my injury
I can't make new memories damn what's the
last thing you remember my wife
you know this guy yeah it's your friend right
what makes you think he's my friend I just
saw it together that's all he's not my friend
if he calls or if he shows up here you give
me a call in my room okay there's a great
Rhythm to the dialogue you kind of learned
to trust your own handwriting where you put
your notes that also becomes really important
you need like a jacket that's got like six
pockets in it particular pockets for particular
things I wonder who he's narrating to you
have to be wary of other people writing stuff
for you that is not going to make sense or
I was going to lead you astray I mean I I
don't know I guess people trying to take advantage
of somebody with this condition he's shaving
his leg it's nice see Christopher Nolan movie
where the dialogue is so clear remember Sammy
jankus
what are the facts how often does he discover
this how is this crafted together he left
his at your table thanks Lincoln Street oh
yeah just go straight out on 6th Street go
east all the way
down he shouldn't be behind a wheel it seems
so dangerous for him to be alone discount
in Natalie car Teddy
John Edwards something or another
God told me his name was Teddy I don't believe
he's lies he killed my wife that's not his
real name Mr Grandma John Gamble
okay okay so the clear-cut answer to the mystery
would have to be at the very beginning of
this story the one in color right because
the one in black and white appears like it's
moving in chronological order
God I gotta get notes like this for an upload
schedule
that's why he was shaving his legs
I mean all signs seem to point to him
I like the soft-spoken coldness to guy Pierce's
performance it's like a hollowness within
his so Hollow so
oh
does he not recall that's what exactly happened
to his wife what do we talk about oh Sammy
Jenkins Sammy's story helps me understand
my own situation I have a more graceful solution
to the memory problem it's not that it's like
it's backwards when he looks down but in a
mirror it's reflective of it all at all
yeah she has also a lost someone she will
help you out of pity solid assessment of an
individual
ah the brilliant carrion Moss must be tough
living according to a couple you mix your
laundry list with your grocery list and you'll
end up eating your underwear for breakfast
I guess that's why you have those freaky tattoos
oh man she embodies that great film Noir performance
here's a copy of his license his registration
photo and all are you sure you want this have
I told you what this man did but even if you
get revenge you're not gonna remember it my
wife deserves Vengeance doesn't make any difference
whether I know about it Amen brother you can
just feel the details and you can feel these
extreme moments even if you don't want to
you put these together and you get the feel
of a person it's interesting seeing these
like crucifer Nolan motifs especially the
use of the flashbacks and the way he shoots
them shoots them like a dream I added an address
in here it's an abandoned place outside of
town um a guy I knew used to do bigger deals
there it's isolated do I owe you I wasn't
helping you for money okay wait is she framing
Teddy you know what we have in common we are
both survivors did she survive something from
Teddy he didn't even inquire why she's all
beat up I met Sammy through work insurance
I was an investigator I'd investigate the
claims to see which ones were phony I had
to see through people's [__] it's useful
experience because now it's my life okay good
Exposition who are you on the phone with we're
gonna find out what someone knew was just
let him talk and watch the eyes if someone
scratches their nose while they're talking
experts will tell you it means they're lying
Sammy was my first real challenge are we gonna
get to see Sammy yo Lenny I thought you split
for good my name's Teddy I guess I've told
you about my condition only every time I see
you the other day you mentioned that maybe
somebody was trying to set you up get you
to kill the wrong guy well I go on fax not
recommendations but thank you you can't trust
a man's life to you little notes and pictures
oh my god he didn't kill your wife you really
want to get this guy don't you killed my wife
I took away my memory he destroyed my ability
to live fascinating I really like he can't
remember this guy but it still feels like
they got a history together I'm checked in
here but I think I've misplaced my key how
you doing Leonard probably in the room right
I really love guy Pierce's performance it's
really like overly gentleman kind of guy this
is not my room no and why is this my handwriting
this was your room but now you're in 304.
I told my boss about the condition and stuff
and he said try and rent him another room
is he lying always get a receipt I'll write
that down hey what time is it quarter one
your rooms he did it right down to always
get a receipt everyone's a goddamn suspect
doctors find some possible damage to the hippocampus
but Sammy can't remember anything for more
than a couple of minutes his wife calls the
insurance company and I get sent in looks
like it's from completely other era and this
guy who couldn't even follow the plot of Green
Acres anymore could do the most complicated
things as long as you learned before the accident
right but every time I see him I catch this
look slide look of recognition familiarity
yeah but he says he can't remember me at all
or is that in your own head that you think
that he remembers this feels like a very interactive
film oh wait oh where am I
oh somebody's bedroom oh he's in carry on
Moss's bedroom you know it's great that you
well it's true helping me I'm helping you
because you help me how so next time you see
me will you remember me
what's happening
eyes open
I thought you split for good he was right
outside what the hell is going on pick up
any three objects foreign
did give him a small shock they kept repeating
the test always with the same objects electrified
uh yeah Natalie right who the [__] is
Dodd I guess I don't have to worry about him
anymore what the [__] have you got me
into oh my God you offered to help me when
you saw what he did to my face how do I know
he did that to your face because I came straight
to you after he did it I showed you what he
did and I asked you to help me oh and I just
take your word yeah she's lying about some
[__] this has nothing to do with you you
helped me out and I'm grateful uh uh doesn't
have the photo I was literally wondering if
you had the photo still I've lost somebody
too his name was
Jenny do kill him maybe I can help you find
him so she did frame him I don't even know
how long she's been gone it's like I've woken
up in bed and she's not here because she's
gone to the bathroom or something dad this
dude's gonna forever be in a state of grief
how horrible how can I heal yeah exactly how
am I supposed to heal if I can't feel Time
Time Heals all wounds and he doesn't get that
it's not a luxury but that's something that's
what he makes a dudes oh gotta take that for
granted don't I and time is still an element
of a Nolan film
like the way they draw these parallels of
a classic film Noir Dynamic with the investigator
detective the woman who needs help but they're
going to be like doing inverses of the tropes
I feel like there's some big twists coming
my way and I'm trying to figure it out
she has also lost someone she will help you
out of pity that's a oversimplification she
identifies and you guys have a bond there's
almost an anime-esque quality to guy Pierce's
performance there you get the impression of
like an apathetic type of delivery but you
could just sense you know sense that it's
all there so much pain we turned on each claim
on the grounds that he wasn't covered from
mental illness his wife got stuck with the
bills and I got a big promotion that is horrible
but it works for me don't leave the way Sammy
couldn't have it and routine make my life
possible conditioning acting on instinct yeah
I mean whoa whoa whoa what's happening
awake where am I what did we just see if is
that was that the flash of how he lost his
memory
just a minute [Music] I love how Heroes to
always act like he's composed and knows what
he's talking about
is that you don't know him is that John G
I don't think so you don't think so you don't
know you didn't write it down I might have
fallen asleep before I did I just fell asleep
so we take him down to his car we come to
get out of town or we're gonna kill him we
can't just walk him out of here tied up and
bleeding how the [__] did you get him
up here I don't know foreign yes I do this
is not my room it must be his room great let's
go no no no no no no
let me clean him up and we March him out of
here with a gun in his back the gun why would
I have a gun it must be his which one
what a great low budget psychological Thriller
this holds up so freaking well so what do
you do now find out what the [__] that
was all about this Teddy guy is too nonchalant
about what just went down hmm I don't feel
drunk
I would love to know what the writing process
of the script was they must have written in
a chronological order first that had to do
a complete rewrite place it backwards like
they must have had an interesting whiteboard
this guy just like went to the bathroom it
wasn't like who's showering
is this guy hired to kill him God put him
on Teddy I'll just get rid of him for Natalie
Dodd what nice penmanship he has this is a
message for Teddy I'm at the mount Christ
Inn on 5th Street room six I need you to come
over as soon as you get this
smart decision well what Mrs jancis didn't
understand was that you can't bully someone
into remembering the more pressure under the
harder it gets okay so is the time of before
a memory restart process happened whatever
it's called restart process happens for him
again can be dependent on how stressful the
situation is for him okay so what am I doing
ah this just happens in the middle of him
ready I'm chasing this guy no he's chasing
me God he really needs a change of clothes
especially he's been running around in that
same shirt all day God white guys Mount Christian
on 5th Street
this guy has a very particular set of skills
it's weird it's background is an insurance
agent but he really moves like he's got some
type of military or police enforcement training
of some sort you know
the window is fine here we're gonna finally
see the origin of what happened to his car
window [Music]
oh damn
okay so what am I doing there that really
sucks
ouch cut it out it's just so interesting because
he's got the same almost the same exact style
of filmmaking he just does everything on on
a much bigger Grant a more Grand scale now
you know is it more refined it knows how to
work like IMAX cameras and all these crazy
big scale things there's still so many similarities
to his filmmaking you know you read it like
a thousand times I enjoy it I always thought
the pleasure of a book was in wanting to know
what happens next but don't be prick just
let me read
can't ever forget you what an ironic line
is a poetry to a lot of this now the police
report mentioned the drugs found in the car
outside of the house the car was stolen but
the prints were all over the stuff they found
in the car just fit in with what they believed
it happened so they didn't chase any of it
up so it's going to be that he killed his
own wife I don't know how I feel about that
if that's the twist I don't know what's happening
I mean it's late everything okay
oh my God this is like the horror movie version
of 50 First Dates
because the police claim the guy was an addict
needing money to score which I think is [__]
because he's not gonna go breaking into places
while he's still gonna snatch that big Fair
assessment so he's a dealer
so fascinated by his wardrobe choice to maintain
wearing a suit specifically we just go to
bed you wait for me to fall asleep go into
the bathroom and you slam the door
oh fascinating Alpha maintain some sense of
having a memory I mean look at Sammy jancis
his own wife couldn't deal with it tell me
if you really believe that Sammy's faking
his condition which you honestly believe why
is it falling on him I believe that Sammy
should be physically capable of making the
memories thank you I thought she just needed
some kind of answer I didn't think it was
important what the answer was ah no what path
did you send her down man what path have you
sent yourself down that sounds like it was
more reflective for you you needed some kind
of answer
ready
I shot Leibowitz
this is the bar where she works wait a boyfriend's
a drug dealer she takes Awards form arranges
Meats he writes messages on the back of these
so her boyfriend killed the goddammit she's
going to use you to protect herself write
this down do not trust her you can't trust
anyone and what exactly is this guy's background
there you happy now I won't be happy until
you leave town oh that's what's crossed off
how did you get this suit the car I have money
from what my wife's death so in your grief
you wandered into a Jaguar dealership
you don't even know who you are yes I do oh
my God that's what he said in his death you
wander around playing detective you don't
even know how long ago it was wait how long
ago was it do not trust her
don't believe his lies
damn no she shouldn't have given me that responsibility
legal responsibility large Finance
never answer the phone
gnarly that is some trippy menacing music
man it just feels like a spiral dog beat the
[__] out of me why why
not Daddy you're safe it's okay love how he
never goes I don't remember any of this goes
with the flow over time I'll go see him yeah
I'll give him some bruises of his own and
tell him to look for a guy called Teddy it's
got dangerous that's just something else okay
I don't know man she seems like such a manipulator
although I'm gonna look like a real [__]
if you actually did get messed up [Music]
you're a liar lady I'm just so suspicious
of everyone here
wait was there a bruise on his knuckle did
he a car this nice you should lock so the
[__] are you
did he hit her and she was making up a story
what a tense Todd film this mess is when you're
at man who's messing with your head calls
himself Dodd wants to know what happened to
Jimmy and his money he thinks I have it he
thinks I took it did you no
he went to meet some guy named Teddy he took
a lot of money with me and he never came back
get rid of Dodge for me I'm not going to kill
someone for money what then kill for your
wife wouldn't you that's different not to
me I wasn't married to her hey don't talk
about my wife oh man this is bad I say whatever
I want and you won't remember I could call
your wife a [__] [__] we could just
be friends
great yes I can say whatever the [__]
I want and you won't have a [__] clue
oh my God [__] you could write yourself
a little note about how much Natalie hates
you [__] guts and that I called your wife
hey don't say another word yeah there it is
you know one of the causes of short-term memory
loss is venereal disease maybe you're of a
one too many disease it turns you into it
what are you doing oh and then she just made
up the whole story we'll still be best friends
did punch her and when she just waited outside
or something what did she do stay focused
good
no man your head's not a filing cabinet that's
what he was all he was doing was looking for
a goddamn pen
oh she just waited this [__] out this
is so stressful write it down come on
what happened what does it look like he beat
the [__] out of me oh you cruel evil woman
if you have all of that information then why
haven't the police found him for you they
don't think he exists I was asleep
[Music]
damn oh
damn
okay so he didn't kill his wife there had
to be a second man but you can't trust your
memory right I don't know what to believe
he took the Dead Man's gun he replaced it
with a sap that he hit me with he left my
gun and he left to get away car he gave the
police a complete package they didn't need
to look for anybody else there is such a clever
menace to this make a step at home at home
one thing
that's why I took the photo
this film has such a great like menacing dread
to it I think this movie is better than a
lot of his other films
what it's the last thing that you do remember
my wife I remember my wife dying that's not
what he said let me know get you another one
she poisoned him or something I know you're
a couple what do you want if I did something
wrong because of my condition you don't believe
someone with this condition nobody believed
Sammy I didn't even believe Sammy
he did not Sammy was faking I have no short-term
memory it's not amazing you're the memory
guy my boyfriend told me about you Jimmy grants
do you know him in fact a cop came by earlier
and was looking for you uh-huh are you teddy
no my name's Leonard what's happened to Jimmy
I don't know that either sorry you don't remember
where you've been or what you've just done
what did you just do I found this in my pocket
pocket did he steal that suit off someone
yeah this would have been just like a couple
years after the Matrix that's neat
oh that's why she here to continue nice come
on proceeds are going to charity help me out
gross
ew on the house thanks
oh that's mean like Sammy if I've done something
like Sammy I thought she was just trying to
catch me with guards so I didn't tell her
what I really thought but I never said that
he was faking just that his condition was
mental not physical uh-huh it's time for my
shot
you found a way to test him
oh no gave the shot again it's time for my
shot hmm
man this little side story about Sammy is
some of the most heartbreaking [__] I've
seen in a while yeah she really thought she'd
call these Bluff that won't hurt
oh no
she went into a coma never recovered oh you
gotta be kidding me he's been home ever since
he doesn't even know that his wife is dead
now I know you fake it you think he's supposed
to recognize somebody you just pretend to
you Bluff it to get a pat on the head from
the doctors so that's exactly what he does
every day
what are you still doing here Lenny well I
guess I just wanted to get something down
before it slipped my mind all right then give
me the keys I'm moving for you it'll be all
right for a minute wait out there it's not
safe for you to hang around here anymore why
not because the cops looking for you he's
been calling you for days now telling you
[__] slipping envelopes under your door
[__] like that how do you know this he
told me he thinks it's funny is Teddy been
calling him up Jimmy's the drug dealer the
cop wants to know how his operations run he's
got some score in mind somehow you're involved
I'm a snitch he's a cop from out of town the
local boys put us together uh okay I'll save
it real wait what was the one before this
now I'm having a hard time remember the placement
I've seen so I was
why did he write that down I get the impression
Teddy's the only one who's truthful with him
and for some reason he wrote that down because
there's something he doesn't want to believe
[Music] hey Jimmy he took Jimmy's Car and
Jimmy's clothes did he kill Jimmy but he's
not gonna bring her along he'll come by himself
right look at the drugs angle to be the best
way to get him you're in the lobby
I'll be right there so did he already extract
his revenge is Teddy the cop I am not smarter
than this movie
[Music] Teddy is the cop Lenny officer Gamel
yeah no never mind I was at officer or Lieutenant
Kim just Teddy this is the directions where
he's going my numbers on the bottom if you
need me you're not coming no it wouldn't be
appropriate I wouldn't be appropriate make
him beg
[Music] this is where the ending happened
that's why Teddy was upset to be returning
back here Teddy you Jimmy Grant expecting
any other Jimmy's out here remember man do
you remember me yeah I remember you why is
he laughing at him well
okay so this guy did not do it I knew he couldn't
trust that take it off your pants too I'm
confused why I don't want to get blood on
them
life back
dude
okay so this guy definitely didn't kill his
wife [Music]
[Music] oh oh we're in color we've converged
the story lines
what have I done is that what he there's a
guy in here he's hurt bad we gotta get him
to a doctor smart smart I've got this memory
thing do I know you no don't worry still breathing
well I don't know so he actually is a cop
this guy's dead ow buddy that [__] killed
you remember me now huh I'm the guy to help
you find him get him oh what's happening he
knew me of course he did your wife he picked
up your brain [__] he's not the guy his
name is James F grants John G check your tattoos
why is he framing him Jimmy's your guy I just
figured we'd make a few dollars on the side
how do you know me the discount end he dealt
out of there the guy at the front desk let
him know if anybody came snooping around why
would he be in the house and kill his wife
and stuff he knew about Sammy why would I
tell him about
few little details you'd rather not remember
what what your wife surviving the assault
her not believing your condition the torment
and and pain and anguish tearing her up inside
the insulin
what it was your wife who had diabetes ouch
oh I guess I can only make you remember the
things you want to be true like old Jimmy
down there he's not the right guy he was to
you that's all that mattered why you're never
gonna know no you won't I will somehow you
won't remember that's done I will know it'll
be different well I thought so too in fact
I was sure of it but you didn't this isn't
the first time that's right the real John
G he's already got it you'll find him over
a year ago he's already dead over a year ago
we found him you killed him but you didn't
remember so I helped you start looking again
this is just the life he chooses to live a
couple of junkies too strung out to realize
your wife didn't live alone but when you killed
him I I was so convinced that you'd remember
but it didn't stick how tragic I took that
picture just when you did it I wanted to see
that face again that's sadistic how many John
G's or James G's I mean [__] Lenny I'm
John G yep my name's John Edward Gamel cheer
up there's plenty of John G's for us to find
unless you know Teddy's not a good guy come
on what are you doing you know what time it
is it's beer o'clock I'm fine oh this is when
he he chooses to live he don't believe his
life it all makes sense I'm not a killer I'm
just someone who wanted to make things right
I just let myself forget what you've told
me
he's not a lot of time this is his life how
unsettling
forget what you've made me do I think I just
want another brother John G to look for you're
a John G oh man so you can be my Dungey
[Music] hey that's not your car it is now
somebody will recognize it somebody will I
think I'd rather be mistaken for a dead guy
than a killer
will you help me find the keys let me find
my feet
wow
some Bleak ass [__] I have to believe
that my actions still have meaning
I have to believe that when my eyes are closed
the world's still here can't trust your memory
[Music] [Applause] a tattoo father now where
was I
damn that holds up so well that was amazing
that was really great oh my God that that
really [__] in my head that was great
all right let's talk about it man I think
I need uh I need to digest that a little bit
that is real heady there's a lot on its mind
and overall just a master class and craftsmanship
man it's so tense and taught and the whole
time I kept going how did they construct this
movie this is one of those films that often
you'll get this with Christopher Nolan is
you want to know what the what is the craftsmanship
behind it how did they develop the scenes
here what did they do in order to bring this
to life to me it's one of Nolan's best films
honestly I see why this movie was so talked
about and you could see like similarities
of this main character amongst many of the
other characters like well there's always
this uh inner conflict with them and there's
a constant nuance and whatnot not always as
as on display as it is here to me this was
so character driven it was so character driven
dealing with a lot of different questions
and themes throughout it didn't get too bogged
down and any of that and it also had a really
unique style and a really unique structure
that would suck you in even more and really
complemented the disorienting nature of its
storytelling without just feeling like a gimmick
I'll get it out of the way I maybe felt like
five minutes of the film maybe five to ten
minutes of it was kind of dragging a little
bit I remember having that thought I cannot
honestly tell you where that thought happened
specifically in the movie though so that's
really my one little criticism is at one point
I thought it but then the movie immediately
had some switch happen where I instantly got
pulled back in uh yeah I thought it was absolutely
brilliant man I think Nolan killed it here
you know for a guy who often makes films about
uh sounds weird to say manipulation this movie
deals so much obviously you know with the
I believe the word Memento has something you
know I'm just going to look it up really fast
because I know Memento or like the physical
items uh like the objects and whatnot but
where does the word come from it means to
remember oh my God it's a double meaning with
your actual mementos that he's using to dictate
The Narrative of his life and it also means
to remember and that you can't trust your
memory whoa so my mind is a little bit like
a little mind [__] right now I'm so used
to saying that with the Nolan film because
of it's like wow look at this Grand level
the master class filmmaking or iMac stuff
and and this to me just blew me away because
of stories it's dealing so much with a nuanced
examination of how memory can be manipulated
of how our memories can be unreliable I just
love how the themes are so like so strong
and and it factors in so much to who they
are as a character like everything was just
complimenting itself so well where sometimes
I feel like something like this and sometimes
with the Christopher Nolan film honestly is
he gets so bogged down in the ideas and it's
and dictating those ideas to the audience
Without Really letting it register to the
characters but on the emotional scale and
even on the physical scale because I love
how the mementos themselves are a form of
manipulation as well he's even manipulating
the facts he's manipulating the the things
the mementos is is literally manipulating
the the entire narrative because this guy
can't grieve and he's got such a conflict
about his own identity in this world and this
is the thing they can give him his sense of
self this is the thing that he give him uh
an actual purpose in life it's really thought
provoking and it it gets you to kind of think
about your own self-perception it makes you
also like my mind's going to be zigzagging
a lot here because we're dealing with so much
about memory it does make you start to question
your own memory because they're talking about
how it could factor into your own biases and
whatnot and the idea that he is trying to
illustrate to Teddy in that one scene in a
diner about like he's relying on cold hard
facts you can't even rely on that and this
is supposed to be the physical representation
of the memory because he's not going to rely
he can't rely on his actual own memory with
the style and the way this was done sometimes
you find yourself trying like I like how the
the scenes whenever they would go backwards
they would still end like the the not the
non-linear ones told in Reverse they would
still end on the scene that came prior because
sometimes I would be having to jog my own
memory of wait so it kind of messes with the
audience in its own way too from a structural
and editing standpoint of wait a minute what
what was the prior scene I need to try to
remember what the prior scene is as the other
multi-layer of having you trying to pick up
on all these Clues and try to remember everything
that's being said because you could tell that
this movie is leading to some big reveal and
you want to kind of figure it out and you're
also trying to try to figure it out with Leonard
along the way as well you're also trying to
remember stuff is it's this fascinating game
about memory and I'm more used to knowing
messing with time and while this movie obviously
deals so much with time and there's this element
of time the conversation as well about how
time is the gift that we get in times of grief
and he is not allotted that but at the same
time a lot seems to be compounded with because
of the fragility of the situation that he's
in and the unreliability of his own memory
that a lot of it also seems to be compacted
with because he he can't grieve that he so
much of this is just in denial as well sometimes
when Teddy is talking to him and they're doing
the fly in the finale or the beginning when
Teddy's talking to him and giving him uh you
know like the the actual truth bombs of the
situation he gets these like little flashes
you know one can argue that maybe it's just
Teddy messing with his perception his whole
perspective of things it's so much of the
perspective of stuff they come in these like
I like the way that Nolan handles those flashbacks
it's kind of like the way he he can do it
on time where it's just these little quick
inserts it's kind of the way like a lot of
us remembers like these brief little moments
in time the disorienting nature of his own
memories makes you then as the viewers suddenly
go wait a minute is this just his imagination
can he trust his memory that what Teddy is
saying that he's actually getting a flash
of an actual memory or is it messing with
his own memory in that moment so you don't
even really know what the entire truth is
I mean it seems like that would be the truth
though I feel like what we got at the end
was the actual truth Leonard already did find
the guy and that Teddy is a corrupt cop who
has been turning him into a vigilante of source
for his own game to make money that would
explain then because they don't make it explicitly
clear that the Dobbs guy was going after Carrie
Anne Moss's character Natalie because he used
to work he thought Jimmy ran off with the
money right did I piece that together I think
I pieced that together and like the performances
too my God we're getting so caught up in and
so caught up in like trying to piece together
my own thoughts here because this movie did
a number on me I love guy Pierce's performance
here you know the at times where he would
seem it's like he always had to set that determination
but there was the way he would play masking
the confusion that he would have at the beginning
of all those scenes and still having this
vulnerability allows you to empathize for
the sky who you know through a lot of the
story you're going you know you can't trust
any of these people but then you start to
question can I even trust my main character
right now even by the very end as dark of
an ending as it is you still actually feel
really sorry for the guy but I thought he
brought a wide array of emotions to Performance
felt very human and yet struck just the right
kind of tone to make this it's like an unforgettable
performance to me because this is the kind
of performance that needs to hit this certain
kind of pitch in order for like because the
plot's a little ridiculous like when you really
break it down it's like it's a little ridiculous
right they make it very believable but it's
it's a little far-fetched because this dude
with this it's not I forget what the condition
is called but this dude with the con with
the memory condition doing all this it's a
little far-fetched I don't know maybe maybe
people can actually pull it off but to me
it's it's a little suspended disbelief right
but the way he captures the grief the way
he captures the obsession the way he captures
the the anger this entire internal struggle
there's a lot of great subtleties he's also
really charming and funny and I think he really
does bring a compelling insight into this
character's fragmented reality essentially
consistent throughout and he really carries
his film so strong thought it was an unforgettable
performance and he really carried this movie
you know sometimes I feel like Nolan lead
characters can be just there to serve it I
mean really I'm just kind of thinking of like
the most part there's always a death provided
a depth provided Hey Leonardo DiCaprio also
had a whole dead wife thing in uh Inception
Booyah and he's also a really smart detective
like character there are these kind of like
know the knee tropes and then carrian Moss
of course man um master manipulator her her
incredible ability to oscillate between being
vulnerable and being manipulative this kind
of character could have felt one-dimensional
but she really wasn't she really brought a
lot of depth to the role and I thought the
ambiguity that you brought where you were
just like what is This Woman's true intentions
so strong it keeps the audience really really
engaged and you're and you're also like what
exactly is a role in Leonard's life what's
going on here it was a great performance and
I like the back and forth that her and Guy
Pierce had but she still had a wide spectrum
of emotions as well you know like her compassion
and tenderness would seem believable but then
her anger and ruthlessness for her own Revenge
was uh so repulsive man she really nailed
it down but she had some great subtlety as
well everyone had some great subtlety and
freaking Joey pants my man uh talk about ambiguity
another guy who you know trying to serve as
like Leonard's guide but you know he's doing
that because he's really manipulating him
and wants to is using him but he would fluctuate
so much between ah no you killed the wrong
guy Leonard uh I think I think maybe Teddy's
the good guy the whole time and the if the
movie does such a good job of making you fluctuate
between is he good is he bad I can't tell
but you really do get a sense that even though
Joey pants likes to use him the teddy likes
to use him that Teddy actually does kind of
like the guy that Teddy does feel sorry for
him and he does that actually like him despite
the fact that he's a a shitty cop who in the
end seems like he actually deserved to die
but they also do have a a great chemistry
that has a lot of tension to it as well with
this great mix of like yeah it was like a
great mix where it would be like frustration
distrust cynicism with like moments that felt
welcoming and and warm at the same time uh
yeah it was the the performances all around
were very powerful as well a lot of great
moral ambiguity to the entire thing and uh
man I'm I'm a little bit blown away by this
and this is one of those things like when
we talked about Oppenheimer that was something
where had some a little bit of time to think
about it like a few minutes and then going
right into it and here you know there's I'm
a little bit more mind blown by this because
this is such an original idea that has a lot
of great things that a hearken back to you
know film Noir tropes uh but there's a lot
on its mind you know that deals with vengeance
Obsession Justice the um uh Truth Versus reality
uh the subjective side of of reality too and
just a entertaining ass movie at the same
time underneath this entire package of like
brilliant Cinema it's just a really entertaining
film I I thought it was exciting and it it
had me suckered in from beginning to end and
there was this one part of me that was like
oh this is like really early Nolan days I
wonder if it's gonna be kind of boring I had
a big concern that that this movie was over
hyped for me and that's partly why I put it
off because you know I came in at an insomnia
which I like Pacino and uh Robin Williams
and and after that I was I think about after
that it was Batman Begins and then all the
other films are now like Prestige and whatnot
so I I thought I'm so used to like this really
exciting Nolan this is like his low budget
Nolan this is gonna be boring it's gonna be
a boring film and it wasn't I thought I genuinely
thought it was one of his best because it
deals so much with self-perception it's on
personal identity sense of self um your own
personal belief system Karma and and uh trauma
I loved it I I loved it I really loved that
movie I'm glad I watched it man that was a
really exciting film with a great grip on
on uh I wonder if like Nolan today would would
make a movie like this because I know he's
like the big Cinema guy now but man I love
this just zeroed in low budget like that's
a lot with a little because it doesn't feel
expensive nor does it feel cheap if that makes
sense uh you know and sometimes like they
told the right story and it seemed like they
they got all the right necessary amounts of
money some stuff is a little questionable
of course of how come cops never chasing down
this guy where you know he's driving around
with a very identifiable car there's gunshots
going off maybe that's something to do with
the Crime Boss stuff or the I mean like Jimmy
was a crime boss right he's worked for someone
so maybe they wouldn't call the cops because
of it then again Teddy was on the case so
maybe he was manipulating stuff there's a
lot of things that where you can kind of fill
in and go maybe this is why this happened
maybe this is why this didn't happen to me
this is why this didn't happen um but overall
yeah I thought it was an amazing film and
again sorry for just like trailing left and
right there was just so much processing of
Amazement from being from having such a marvelous
splendiferous experience with this movie that
I was processing simultaneously we're trying
to talk about it I should have made notes
that would have really helped me out uh but
right now yeah um thank you for being here
and I will talk with you all soon [Music]